so last Monday I did a story where I
discussed that I had finished up my
taxes for 2018 and that as a result of
Donald Trump's new tax plan my effective
federal tax rate dropped about 13
percent it was like 26 point something
percent for the 2017 tax year and it
dropped to 22 point something percent
for the 2018 tax year about a 13 percent
drop and my focus in the clip was that
economically speaking it didn't really
make much sense for the US economy the
responses were so all over the place
misunderstanding how taxes work
misunderstanding how economics works
misunderstanding even what I was saying
that I gathered some of the more common
themes from the responses that I just
want to address and I rarely do these
sort of point/counterpoint response type
things where I do a clip and then people
respond and I respond to the responses
but there were so many responses to the
tax cut clip that were so fundamentally
flawed that I thought it would be useful
so these are this is not every argument
made about how stupid I am
but these are some of the more common
themes that I saw let's put the first
one up on the screen this is an argument
that I saw a bunch give back the money
to government anyway the government
needs it for global warming this is the
idea which I actually mentioned in the
video which is David if you think your
tax rate should be higher just send in
more money to the IRS you can always do
that you can always send in more money
if you want it makes no difference
whether I choose to pay more this is not
about the amount of taxation I believe
is right for me to pay this is about the
fact that economically speaking it
doesn't make sense to give me on the
basis of having passed through income
and this deduction that Trump put in
place it's not economically logical to
give me a 13 percent tax cut that's what
I'm saying if I just write a check to
the IRS yeah they'll take the money but
the money isn't budgeted to be used in
any kind of stimulative way you can't
run a country on the idea that the
people who think they should pay more
will send more money in because
you might want to it's ridiculous I
mentioned it in the video it's just not
economic policy okay that's number one
can't even believe I have to address
that it was in the video I said in the
video if you're gonna say David pay more
here's why it doesn't make sense okay
another theme that I saw in terms of
responses people talking about me
complaining about my taxes going down
for example Tim Brock 1000 on YouTube
saying behold the first guy to ever
complain about having a lower tax
invoice totally misses the point of the
segment I'm not complaining about paying
less in taxes what I'm saying is that if
I put aside what puts more or less money
in my pocket and I explain what's good
for the economy the economy is not
better off because certain business
income has been taxed at a lower rate or
there's a deduction for a portion of
business income the whole point is it
doesn't matter whether I like having
more money or not that that's exactly
the opposite of what the segment was
about it was about the economic impact
and why I would get a 13 percent tax cut
this got very quickly into another theme
about earning the money versus earning
the tax cut okay a lot of people
commented things like for example what
did I do to earn the money I earned
great question David this is straight
out of the libertarian playbook okay in
the segment I said what have I done to
earn this tax cut okay I got hundreds of
responses from people saying David you
earned the money by working this is a
total semantic game I get that I earned
the money by working the question is
what did someone in my specific
situation do to deserve getting a tax
cut versus people in other situations
getting tax increases or decreases once
again the responses are all about me
specifically it's an illustration of how
economic policy works and I'm pointing
out that it doesn't make economic sense
to cut the taxes of people in the
particular business owning situation in
which I find myself okay another theme
David just spend the money it'll be good
for the economy one example you do
realize that you can spend the money
that you earned right and spending this
money helps the economy it's okay
to spend your money this is the whole
point okay
people with businesses who aren't
incorporating that tax cut into their
personal spending month-to-month are not
that likely to spend the money I did the
same thing I always do with my tax
refund I saved it this isn't a hugely
economically stimulative thing to do I
wasn't counting on that money i budgeted
for the business and for everything for
the year on the basis of not getting the
cut I don't buy random things when I get
a little extra money I save the money
and this is exactly why it is not a good
way to stimulate the economy and people
who are actually wealthy do you think
that they go and spend that money on
stuff in the traditionally economically
stimulative way no they don't
this is why this type of pass-through
business income tax cut doesn't make
sense and then lastly the charity
argument why don't you give your extra
money to charities that's perfectly fine
it does not end up being very
economically stimulative it does not
justify tax cuts for the rich the
question isn't what can David Pakman
come up with to do with money that
results from a lower tax rate at the end
of the year the question is what should
government policy be around how to best
tax and spend government revenues me
giving money to charity is fine but it's
not policy it's at my discretion only
part of that charity donation even goes
to doing the good that charities do
there's overhead and all sorts of other
stuff so it really doesn't make sense
and then the last one which we don't
have a screenshot of is David you should
just reinvest the money into the
business to grow the business
exponentially
stop people saying that online you don't
grow a business exponentially with a
single tax cut which is likely not even
going to be permanent since much of what
has been done by the new tax plan is
temporary anyway it would be really bad
planning to on the basis of a tax cut
one year start doing whatever it is that
these people imagine would be done with
the money so just a lot of nonsense
responses from people who just don't
really seem to understand what the point
is of pointing out at a policy level
what doesn't doesn't make sense rather
than can david pakman donate the money
to charity that's not really the issue
here